well it's good to be home but we can't
get too comfortable because we're taking
our little news show on the road later
this week
uh we're uh drew's newsing from philly
hey philly we're coming yeah maybe some
cheese steaks and uh
um and then um we're also coming from
our nation's capital washington d.c
it's
it's so epic yeah we have we have a news
desk we will travel so if you want us to
come to your city hit us up on social
media maybe you'll see us right there
that's right have desk will travel hit
us up please welcome us or request us
we will show up i can't wait for philly
in dc i know i know well there's no
better way to kick off this news than
when one of the biggest superstars in
digital comedy right now
he's got millions of followers on
instagram who are absolutely hooked on
his incredible characters he recently
took his talents to washington as well
here's a look at benito skinner
hey everyone
usually i start off with a big coffee
sorry they're like really strict in here
hey jenny i booked you a nail
appointment love yeah i didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative
hi white house is a scooper
i don't think so
oh doesn't matter
[Music]
oh thank you honey
these suck sophie on xcx put on
chemtrails anastasia get out here for
your swim lesson honey
[Applause]
please welcome back to the show benito
skinner aka
betty drama
literally like i'm in heaven oh my god
you're the biggest deal in the world i'm
so oh i can't i will never and by the
way i posted your video that you did uh
you do danielle from ever after the film
i was in and you're danielle but it's
everything that movie is my favorite
movie ever the wings no it was my
fantasy give me one line as daniel oh my
god well i think i have to do just like
breathe
just
breathe
it was
no it was
that was my fantasy come to life i yeah
it was an honor all right well let's
jump into the news um hey oh we got to
talk about this we're you know we're
back in the city and all summer long the
talk of the town has been
sex and the city are you ready sjp
cynthia nixon and kristen davis they're
shooting the hbo max spin-off and just
like that which is what it's called and
vanity fair reports you can get all the
leaked info you need on instagram and
online there have been
tons of photos of the ladies on set
revealing new cast members like nicole
arie parker and shots of carey in bed
with mr big
and um okay i feel
torn about this because i am looking
forward to this more than anything i've
ever looked forward to in my entire life
and i feel like
about these leaks they feel like how
like dessert for me you know like i
devour it and then i just feel bad about
my choices because i
i i want to wait i want to see the whole
thing when it comes out thoughts no it
so okay so i also devour it it's kind of
like if like music leaks and i'm like i
can't touch that like the artist
wouldn't want me to and then i'm like
play it again
all right well your story next benny oh
my god my turn next we're gonna talk
about the latest dating term on this one
uh wait how do you guys do this
i feel like i'm in like fifth grade i
have to read in front of the class by
the way if someone told me like just
come up with a character out of thin air
i would feel the same way so okay
okay my turn next we're going to talk
about the latest dating term on the
block why am i reading this like that
roach
[Laughter]
like literally chris jenner character
style reports um roaching refers to when
the person you're dating is sleeping
with a ton of other people and not
telling you about it that's also called
being a horrible person
there's a really simple thing you can
say if you know of even just one person
he's hooking up with other than you
get out the raid spray it
drew
have you ever been roached oh well i
mean i just assume here's the deal i i
think unless you're exclusive you're not
exclusive you know so you should just
assume uh you're getting roached and
ironically it doesn't bug me i think pun
intended yes totally intended i just
think until you have that convo of like
you and me and no one else right yeah
you just should sort of just
accept the facts that they're getting it
but i do like when new vernacular comes
into our zeitgeist and we can now say oh
she's roaching he's a roach i think
that's fun i think it's fun too and
honestly like it's it has the right like
tenor like the tone for what you're
doing you are roaching yeah like you're
vile you're a roach but uh
we have something else to do though i'm
very excited because um
we built a brand new digital studio it's
upstairs it is stunning it is gorgeous
it's fun giving me like mtv and the 80s
vibes and we are so lucky because benny
you are gonna be our very first you're
gonna christen it and we are gonna do it
together so thank you for uh doing the
inaugural digital piece with
[Applause]
and we're us for it
[Music]